so i have the complex number cosine of
two pi over three
or two thirds pi plus i sine of two
thirds pi and i'm going to raise that to
the 20th power and what i want to do is
first plot this number in blue on the
complex plane and then figure out what
it is raised to the 20th power and then
try to plot that and i encourage you to
pause this video and try this out on
your own before i work through it
so let's first focus on this blue
complex number right over here it's
clearly written in polar form and the
angle is two-thirds pi
two-thirds pi or two over or two pi over
three
radians
and it's a and it's and its magnitude of
this complex number is clearly one and
to make that a little clearer you could
write it in kind of the pure polar form
where you have its magnitude out front
so it's cosine of 2 over 3 pi
plus
i sine
of 2 over 3
pi so you could write it just like that
and when you look at that the angle is 2
over 3 pi and so that would get us let's
see this is 0 this is pi we're going to
go 2 3 of the way 2 pi each of these is
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12. each of
these is pi is is pi over 12. so we're
gonna go
two thirds of the way would be eight
pi's over twelve so one two three four
five six seven eight
and the way i was able to reason through
that is that two thirds pi is the same
thing as eight pi over 12 each of these
segments is pi over 12 so i just counted
eight of them
so that's that number but now let's try
to raise it now let's try to raise it to
the 20th power
let me clear this
and to do that we're going to use
euler's formula and euler's formula you
might remember tells us that e to the i
theta is equal to cosine of theta plus i
sine
plus i sine of theta
and so you see right over here this is
already written in that form where theta
is two thirds pi so we can rewrite what
we have in blue here as e let me write
it over here
as e to the two thirds pi
i
and then of course we're raising that to
the 20th power
we're raising that to the 20th power and
this simplifies things dramatically
because here if i try to multiply this
thing
if i had 20 of these things and i
multiplied them together that would get
really really really hairy really fast
but here i can just use exponent
properties
this is going to be the same thing as e
to the if i raise something to exponent
and then raise that to an exponent i can
just take the product of the exponents
so this is e to the 20
times
over 3
pi
i
which is equal to
e
to the 40
over
40 over 3
pi
i
now
this
is this number raised to the 20th power
but this is a awfully large angle right
over here i mean if we're thinking 40
over 3 pi let's just try to digest this
over 3
pi
this is the same thing as this is the
same thing let's see 40 divided by 3 is
13 and 1 3. this is the same thing as 13
and 1 3
times pi and we know that going 2 pi 2
pi radians gets you around the unit
circle once so this is going over six
times around the unit circle to get to
or around i should say not the units or
going six times around the i guess going
in circles in order to get to the point
we want to so in order to simplify this
a little bit
let me subtract the largest multiple of
2 pi that i could figure that to kind of
get this in as small of a form as
possible because we know an angle if we
have some angle it's equal to that angle
plus
some multiple of 2 pi where k is any
integer so k could also be negative we
could be subtracting a multiple of 2 pi
so let me subtract let's see the largest
multiple of 2 pi that i could subtract
here is going to be 12 pi
so let me subtract 12 pi from this so if
i subtract 12 pi
so i'll do it down here so 13 and 1 3
pi
minus 12 pi remember i'm just trying to
subtract the largest multiple of 2 pi
that i can so minus 12 pi
is going to oh whoops already wrote pi
minus 12 pi
13 and one third minus 12 is one and one
third that's going to be one and one
third
pi
or we could write it as four
thirds pi
so this
this complex number is going to be
equivalent to
e to the four thirds pi
i and this makes it much simpler and
much easier for me to plot so four
thirds pi or the same thing as one and
one third pi
so this would be pi and now we have to
just go another one third pi and each of
these are twelfths so if we go four
twelfths pi so each of these sorry each
of these are pi over 12. so we go four
pi over 12. so one two three four gets
us right over there
and so this is so this number is the
20th power is this which is equivalent
to this which we've plotted right over
there
now what if we wanted to take it to
let's say the 21st power well then we
would then we would increase the angle
by another 2 pi over 3 or 8 pi over 12.
so we would increase the angle by 1 2 3
4 5 6 7
8 and we would go right over there so
how does this make conceptual sense well
the number to the first power
was right over here that was our
original number in blue right over here
if you raise it to the second power then
you're increasing the angle by two
thirds pi you're increasing the angle to
go there you raise to the third power
you increase the angle by two thirds pi
you go over there
fourth power you get back here fifth
sixth seventh eighth ninth tenth
eleventh twelfth thirteenth fourteenth
fifteenth sixteenth seventeen eighteen
20th power gets us right over there